what does the next chapter of life look
like for adrienne houghton
i want to be a mom fast forward three
years and adrian houghton's dream is a
reality
i think that would be like the next
chapter is building a family and
still being able to do all the things
that i do but at the same time i just
think that would be probably a great way
for my life to come full circle so
that's what i'm most excited about the
triple threat shared the big surprise on
tuesday announcing her bundle of joy
with this stunning black and white image
on instagram adrian and her husband
israel houghton cradling their newborn
son named ever james
[Music]
in the caption she touches on their
challenging journey to baby quote we
have quietly prayed while sitting on
this most magnificent secret for the
last nine months he is worth every tear
every disappointment every delayed
prayer every ivf cycle every miscarriage
everything
but now that ever's here all the proud
parents feel is gratitude grateful to
god to our angel surrogate and to all of
our friends and family who have stood
with us for over five years on this
journey he's here and we have never been
happier to lose sleep it is something we
are working on
that's a good time thank you
adrian's never been shy about sharing
her story with fans in may before
wrapping up the reel the co-hosts shared
promises they made to themselves
adrian's was to start a family mine was
not to give up on my dream of being a
mother you know we get these bad notices
and it'll be like and it didn't work
this time or you know i've done multiple
cycles of ivf and so many other things i
don't know why i refuse
to let this be the end of my story the
following month e.t sat down with adrian
and she seemed at peace with letting the
universe do its thing it's not a matter
of if it's a matter of when you become a
mother thank you for publicly sharing
that journey how is everything going
everything's going really well i feel
like i'm at a better place where i feel
like okay guys
i've wrapped my mind about what i think
about it
especially now with social media it's
really hard and even with a show like
the real i felt like had i been talking
about it on the real people felt that
they could speak into it and i was not
prepared for that little did we know at
the time that ever would soon be here
and i think that's okay to recognize
what you're ready for and what you're
not and hold sacred to you what is
sacred and when asked about turning the
big 4-0 next year adrian made it clear
her top priority health and wellness
what are your three big goals for this
next decade i want to be
that like healthy person i want to be
that because if i'm honest i didn't have
that in my
life i didn't have that in my mom and
even now my mom is like
do it for your future kids because you
want to lead by example that for me
would be really important not for like
oh i want to look on a bikini but like i
want to actually live a healthy
lifestyle and be an example of that to
my kids
[Music]
you